les travaux ont commencé au parc du
courrier saint martin à montigny le
bretonneux une mare de 300 mètres cubes
est en construction l'aménagement est
écologique luron 10h fait grâce à l'eau
de pluie le but en fait c'est qu'elle
soit alimenté de façon naturelle donc il
ya des nous qui vont être créés et on va
récupérer il ya une école derrière et on
essaie de récupérer les eaux de la
toiture et de la cour de récréation
le parc du port et saint martin souhaite
installer la nature dans la ville un
jardin pédagogique créé en partenariat
avec la ligue de protection des oiseaux
accueillera une vingtaine d'espèces dans
des nichoirs et hôtels à insectes sur
une île parc est ouvert à tout le monde
le l'espace
du jardin pédagogique sera un petit peu
protégés pouvoir alerter vraiment les
visiteurs sur le fait que c'est que de
repos
quiétude pour les animaux
es12
à privilégier
cet espace dédié à la nature sera le
premier dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines les travaux
devraient être terminés le 28 juin et le
parc disposera en plus d'une mare d'une
aire de jeu tout en bois et d'un terrain
multisports